what is because this whole la podcast
scene is does seem a little bit uh dead
it's gay they're all gay
they're all gay
they're
you know i'm not even and i won't even
name specific names but yeah the whole
drama that's going on in the la
podcasting it's one of the gayest things
i've ever seen this is like high school
level drama where they're like calling
each other and they're talking [ __ ] and
they're threatening each other and it's
like guys in new york drama is
everywhere you can't afford your rent
yeah so it's actually real drama like
the new york podcast scene is somebody
being like i am homeless it's it's a
weird thing yeah it's a weird thing how
everyone is so poor in new york this is
people in manchester talking [ __ ] about
each other in new york the drama is like
my parents just kicked me off my
family plan and i'm 38. i'm 38 and i
don't have a phone
my roommate moved out i was not able to
secure another roommate for that room
this month
i'm actually going to kill myself
new york dramas like people hang
themselves people try to kill themselves
yeah
my my bet is covered in rat feces
i i just you know what it is i think
about new york do you go to like people
have money too like big j's got money
big jazz money you gotta got talent got
a nice apartment big j is one of the
funniest people but it's not
nice this is what new york is new york's
nothing's nice it's like everything's
expensive you're like it's this sucks
it's dirty there's garbage everywhere in
front of your building money in new york
you have to have like a hundred million
dollars it's [ __ ] wild crazy it's a
wild thing and you go down to tribeca
one of the most expensive neighborhoods
in new york yeah everything looks like
[ __ ] dude it looks like a heroin dead
everywhere yeah it's like this is like
one of the most expensive buildings like
what the [ __ ] is going on it's tiny yeah
it's true it's wild
well it's just a different life yeah
it's a different life and it makes you
funnier
it does
but the funniest people in the world
come from la
the funniest people in the world are
good-looking surfers and people that are
mixed martial artists
that's where funny comes funny comes
from hot people
l.a just needs to struggle comes from
when hot people get bored yeah if we
know one thing about comedy it's when a
hot person is bored that's when the
genius comes it's true when a hot person
has nothing to do that day they open
their mouth and the genius comes out
the biggest struggle for like la
comedians this is the one you hear it's
like it's like dude i struggled dude i
was a doormat at the comedy store the
biggest struggle is when they actually
have to do comedy yeah like the biggest
struggle is when we actually have to do
it it's like the vast majority of it
it's like here's a photo with me kind of
doing it and then when they actually
when when people actually like go like
do something
that's why a lot of the funny people out
here whether it's me annie
bill burr and i'm not saying i'm any in
any of the categories of these i'm not
putting us in any category but like
sebastian those are east coast guys yeah
those are the east coast people oh yeah
they're all all the funny ones are east
coast guys right yeah that are
transplants yeah i think i mean nobody's
really from l.a who the [ __ ] from l.a
i don't know yeah none of them are
nobody right well they're just dalia i
guess
delhi is from l.a yeah and he's funny
i don't really know his stand up that
well i don't either i don't think i've
ever heard him tell a joke
he's a funny guy i think what he does to
women is funny
i'm a fan
i'm a fan of that
i said women
they're all adults i backed them up on
this
these young women
i feel bad for the guy it's like it's
like we're all gonna pretend that hot
that 18 year olds aren't hot right yeah
they're hot tim by the way tim dillon
his view from his i don't want to give
too much information but it's directly
into beverly hills high school
into the cafeteria you look down at the
sponsorship program
before it's like 17 years
by the way you know what's funny i'm
texting true geordie you know him
this massive busy british guy yeah i
think because it's a i i have this irish
twink i talked to and i hang out with
i'm texting trajority i think it's the
irish twink
literally this is the this is
the conversation i have with true jordi
that was i swear to god i'm reading
i'm reading
the conversation okay
um
[Music]
listen to this i'm not even kidding
he goes this branded child versus bobby
leash is wild bro it's a car crash hope
you're in the uk soon and then i go i'm
gonna
call you in an hour i said call me when
you wake up winky face we'll plan it
that's true jordy he goes sweet thanks
so i think then he goes then he texts me
he goes you awake bro do you know what
he looks like
get him to jordy i swear to god
look at true jordy okay
this guy's this is what you want oh no
you want a twink you don't like yeah but
this guy's a tank listen to this he
texts me
i text him right i go
you awake bro
you awake bro ready he texts me back
yeah just listen to your podcast about
brendan raping you i'm crying laughing i
text him back you're allowed to rape me
you're allowed to rape me
he takes me back i know because you
won't say anything because you want it
to be about the work i respect that lol
he goes you know when you may be in
london i go i'm flying you here did you
forget
he doesn't understand you're stroking
your [ __ ] though
i'm flying you here did you forget well
i know here's the thing i know this type
of texting yeah you are masturbating
while you're doing this
it was in my hand maybe and then i go
i'm flying here did you forget now i
start to worry i'm like is this twink
does he have like a dementia which i'm
fine with but he goes i go oh who is
this and he goes oh true jordy brian i'm
like oh my god
how embarrassing
i felt really embarrassed about that
that's hilarious but
you know nothing's nothing chris did is
proven no so the reality is i'm a person
where i go hey also i don't think what
he did
was it wasn't illegal and i don't give a
[ __ ] if you think a guy's creepy
it doesn't matter i don't [ __ ] care
dude and there's a lot of [ __ ]
there's a lot of creepy people in fact
most people are creepy the worst you
just don't know about their [ __ ]
creepiness louis c.k it was just being a
creep right creepy a little creepy dude
be a little [ __ ] it happens dude it's
it's the worst thing delia did was that
he produced a school play
it's the worst thing he did was he he i
think he funded and produced his school
play
i don't i i don't actually know that he
did anything my understanding when it
was never been proven it was all like 18
or 19 girls it was like a girl that was
like 17. i guess when we found out she
was 17. this is he always said this was
the creepiest thing that he did right he
found out she was 17 then like a year
later yeah after she had turned 18 he
hit her up again
and that's a little bit it's a little
bit it's good memory it's not but it's
not [ __ ] grooming it's not a teacher
he's not a [ __ ] person
dude he likes hot young girls right most
guys like hot young girls most guys
don't have the opportunity to get hot
young girls right so they they go they
deal with their [ __ ] hey [ __ ]
tag-wise you [ __ ] your head
and so nothing was proven yeah and
even if whatever was proven i think
everything that he was accused of was
just sort of him being a little bit of a
douchey
creepy dude which most guys are right
most guys most guys are way [ __ ]
worse than that to be honest with you
most guys are [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] um
so i don't i never really
you know i think it's kind of funny i
think it's all funny like i tease these
guys and i talk about the stuff on my
shows and i think a lot of people in la
think that like legion of skanks and me
that we like are trying to troll them
it's like no dude it's just sort of the
elephant in the room it's a story when
callum gets [ __ ] canceled for
something it's a big story in comedy and
to not talk about it and not talk about
it in a funny way it's a story where
it's like
20 years ago yeah
it you know listen i don't whatever
everyone's experiences and i've talked
about it before where i go is it
possible
that he had one idea of the night she
had another idea i'm sure very possible
very popular and this was not
what it's being portrayed as
uh and that when we look at those
dynamics of people that meet up maybe
they're drinking they hook up and then
you know you 20 years also soulless
actors there's la solas i mean why i
this is it's this is my thing with
meghan markle she's like oh they're
racist and i'm like of course you're
racist but you're an actress yeah so i
don't i can't believe i'm gonna believe
you
i'm choosing between the british
reptilian royal family and an la actress
they're the same person yeah i'm like
these you know
yeah it's uh
yeah i feel you know a lot of it's it's
just a silly
they they got so it's almost like you
say like i know pete davidson pretty
well right yeah and sometimes i'll talk
about him on my show
and i feel bad sometimes because i'm
like i really like i've always really
liked pete always been a really sweet
heart of a guy right but he's so famous
that it's i'm not talking about the pete
davidson that i knew from the comedy
scene i'm talking about this celebrity
thing that's [ __ ] kim kardashian and
roasting kanye it's like it's so much
bigger
than and and i would feel bad if pt's
never heard us like talking [ __ ] right
it's not even really talking [ __ ] just
sort of poking fun and making fun of the
whole situation yeah um he might come to
me one day like hey dude why would you
say that that like hurt my feelings and
i was like dude
you don't have feelings anymore you're
famous you're all right you're a
billionaire you just gotta get release
yourself and also like i don't really
feel bad for people that are [ __ ]
millionaires that get made fun of online
i don't feel bad for you that's right
you that's that's your [ __ ] biggest
problem i feel bad is that people on
reddit are saying mean words are you out
of your [ __ ] mind you're a
millionaire right and you care about
what somebody on reddit says there are
people that you cannot eat yeah there
are people that don't have the money to
pay their rent they cannot get their
kids insulin
right
now so those those people my audience
we know them
jeremiah watkins is doing the star map
in l.a
trying to show people
he's flipping signs he's just trying to
show people
he's selling fruit with mexicans right
now on the freeway jeremiah watkins is
trying to sell bottles of water on the
405.
so the reality is it's you know
those are the people you go it's you
know
people could say whatever they want
it's just kind of like i learned a long
time ago i have a very thick skin i get
trolls i got i got trolled by the opium
anthony subreddit years ago to the point
where like i was posting i was going
back at them and it was like they went
[ __ ] dude they i mean it was like they
need their own subreddits that were
dedicated to me right and it just
literally gave me a thick skin to it
right there's nothing that anybody could
say there's no word here's here's what's
happening this is the physical action a
stranger somewhere in the world is going
like this
right whether they're good words or bad
words the physical action is actually
what it is my name tim dillon is the
same name as a guy who works at marvel
and literally in his twitter handle he
says not the comedian yeah because all
day
every day
people just tweeted this guy go you're
fat i hope you get hated
you i hope you get aids and die
you're a fascist
you piece of [ __ ] you sat next to alex
jones you did a podcast and this guy's
like i don't know what's happening yeah
dude i'm